في سياق تعليقه على اعلان وزير الامن
القومي اتمار اتفاقه مع نتنياهو على
التصديق على انشاء الحرس الوطني قال زعيم
المعارضه من الافضل الا يؤسس حرس وطني تحت
امره بنجافير وصفه
بمهرج التيك توك الخطيره الذي لم يخدم في
الجيش لدقيقه واحده واتهم لبيدا في حديث
مع موقع يد يعوت احرنوت نتنياهو بتقديم
وعود يدرك انه لن ينفذها ووصف الخطوه
بالجنونيه
انضم الينا من الناصره ايهاب جبارين
الباحث المختص في الشؤون الاسرائيليه
الجبارين هل نتنياهو بالفعل يقدم
وعودا لا يستطيع تنفيذها كما يقول
يعني شك ان مساله الثقه ما بين
ارباب هذا الائتلاف والمعارضه وبالذات
تحديدا الثقه بنيامين نتنياهو كشخص اظن ان
هي مساله يعني ليست بالهينه ان يعطوها هذه
الثقه بالذات ان يعني من كلاسيكيات
الحكومات الاسرائيليه او اسرائيل عموما
انها كانت تنكث بالمواثيق خارجيا بين يمين
نتنياهو تبنى هذه الاستراتيجيه وسوقها
داخليا لكي يحاول ان يصووق مساعيه امام
شركائه ولاحظ يعني على سبيل المثال ما
رايناه يوم امس من اتفاقيه ما بين يمين
نتنياهو وبين جبير هي كلاسيكيه يعني حتى
كل مواثيق الائتلاف الحكومي على مدى شهرين
ونصف تقريبا التي تم ابرامها كلها تم
توثيقها بالحرف الواحد وتدوينها والتوقيع
عليها الى هذا الحد لا يوجد ثقه ببين يمين
نتنيه وليس فقط من المعارضه بل حتى من
الشركاء ولاحظ هي نقطه كذلك مهمه جدا
عندما طلب رئيس دوله اسرائيل بان يسموا
الطواقم
التي سوف تخوض المفاوضات بني جانس وكان
طاقمه كان جاهزا منذ اشهر تم تسميته يعني
فورا ولكن لبيد انتظر بان يقدم الكود على
هذه الخطوه الى هذه الدرجه هو لا يثق ببين
يمين نتنياهو كان يريد كذلك ان يرى اي
الشخصيات سوف
يرمي بها الى هذه
ان يجيب
ويحاول الجمع بين هذه الاطراف ما هو ما هي
الفرص في ان يتم التوافق على على امر ما
يعني هي بنهايه المطاف هي مساله نوايا اظن
ان بدون ان يمين نتنياهو يحاول ان يكسب
الوقت حاليا امام جمهور منتخبين لانه باي
شكل من الاشكال نحن راينا بل هناك حديث
جاد لان المظاهرات سوف تتخذ اتجاها اخر
تتخذ فيكتور اخر من
المعارضين للتعديلات القضائيه الى مظاهرات
للمؤيدين لهذه التعديلات القضائيه يعني
هذا بدنا نراه في الحديث عنه في ايام
المقبله يوم الخميس على سبيل المثال
فبالتالي وفق هذه المعادله نتنياهو الان
مشغول بالتسويق هذه الفتره ولاحظ انه
استغل بطابع الامر استغل
فتره العطله للكنيست لكي يحاول ان يجلس
على طاوله المفاوضات ايضا كلمات اخرى هي
اسهل بالنسبه اليه لتسويق ذلك بل اضف من
ذلك وهي مهمه نقطه مهمه جدا بدنا منه انه
عندما خرج الى
سوق هذا الاتفاق مع بين كبير اخرج كل
ابواقه الى الاعلام العبري لمحاوله احتواء
الحدث امام جمهور المنتخبها شكرا جزيلا من
الناصره ايهاب جبارين الباحث المختص في
الشؤون الاسرائيليه